and now it's time for bombing reviews
with Chester a bomb
tonight's review the incredible home
oh my god this is the greatest movie
ever received in my life
there's this guy who has a problem he is
not supposed to get angry because when
he does he turns into a giant only he's
Natsu chubby he's freakin pissed off so
he traveled to Brazil which was like a
bunch of his covered in cardboard boxes
kind of like my house a good day mm
after Hulk Hogan because the two are
very similar except for one difference
one is real and what is not
there's no way all cocaine is real he's
just a big puppy Sisi and money and
chasing after the guy is like you
wouldn't like me when I'm angry
and he starts growing leaps of these
pants how is it his pants always stay on
it makes no sense I don't care how big
you are there are no pant sizes for
Jolly Green giant's and this is British
guy who's like I want to be the hook too
but the Hulk is like pizza so the
British guys like they don't care what
he says I'm going to be a ho I'm going
to work out eat my vegetables and inject
myself with radioactive poison so the
British guy turns into a Hulk who I
guess is wearing the same stretchy pants
and he's like I am the hook too and the
Hulk is like wait a minute
it's a result and I'm like you know that
just never happened or was it just a
crack fantasy it seemed like a crack
fantasy not an inmate said how can the
movie about a Big Green Monster be so
boring that's what made no sense about
it so any ways to alter like in your
library
your whole case like diva the hook it's
like any other guy is like okay you win
correctly and I'm not really sure what
happens the Hulk is meditating and he
smiles that's it I was thinking well
that's a weird ending but suddenly
Ironman chose down I'm not kidding
Ironman is in this movie Iron Man I
swear it did that smoke anything Iron
Man and he's like I'm putting a group
together are you interested
and I'm like a groove what the hell is
that wait a minute Iron Man the whole of
the Marvel characters oh my god Marvel
is putting together a baseball team
spider-man will be the shortstop
lulu-nee will be the pitcher and the
whole media empire cuz you do not want
to piss off that umpire he will eat you
and they'll call it the major leagues I
am so proud to be african-american but
not a bum that sucks
this is history bum say JJ help me see
the baseball team a human with the duck
his premise